between September 16th and 18th 1982 a
campaign of killing took place at the
Sabra and shatila refugee camps in
Lebanon what happened was described by
the UN as an act of genocide with the
backing of invading Israeli forces a
right-wing Lebanese Christian armed
group called The falange attacked the
Palestinian camps in Beirut according to
multiple reports up to 3 500 men women
and children were killed for nearly 40
hours civilians were raped tortured and
mutilated
[Music]
the phalange had gone into the camps
claiming they were looking for fighters
from the Palestinian Liberation
Organization who they wrongly blamed for
the assassination of their leader
Lebanese president-elect Bashir Jamaya
the falange in the PLO were fighting on
opposite sides of Lebanon Civil War
and just a few months earlier Israel's
Army had invaded allied with the
phalanges it surrounded the camps and on
the orders of Israeli defense minister
Ariel Sharon the phalanges went in and
while the massacre was taking place
Israel's Army was accused of standing by
and letting it happen
for about
it
the killings provoked International
condemnation the UN said Israel was
directly guilty of involvement an
Israeli judicial commission concluded
that Ariel Sharon was personally
responsible and called for him to be
dismissed from his position he resigned
but in 2001 was elected as prime
minister
foreign
[Music]
decades later survivors and their
relatives are still demanding
accountability